what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there are so many MCU projects that
are coming up that are going to be
extremely important for the MCU moving
forward of course everything is going to
be leading up to Avengers Secret Wars a
movie where tons of Heroes that we know
and love are going to be coming together
not just in one universe but in many
different universes to take on Kang the
Conqueror and his evil variants however
there is a path to Secret Wars filled
with many important projects along the
way including the Fantastic Four the new
Avengers team which will be revealed in
Avengers King Dynasty and another doctor
strange film Doctor Strange 3 which will
come out before Secret Wars and luckily
enough and excitingly enough we have
updates about all of these projects
today and also if you haven't heard John
Bernthal is returning as The Punisher
and also According to some reports from
some insiders Kristen Ritter is also
going to be returning as Jessica Jones
they will join join Charlie Cox's Matt
Murdoch slash Daredevil by making their
way over from the Netflix Marvel series
Defenders world to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so the Defenders are making
their way to the MCU which of course
will add to just even more Heroes
appearing in secret Wars now we're going
to start off by talking about the
Fantastic Four because casting news has
been happening pretty much every week
for the past several months but it looks
like we are indeed getting closer but
what we've typically heard a lot about
as far as casting is concerned is
casting news around Mr Fantastic and The
Invisible Woman which of course everyone
is dying to know well who are they going
to get to play these roles but today we
have news about Ben Grimm aka the thing
and what's really interesting here is
that this new report actually lines up
with some old reports that we heard
letting us kind of hone in on who
exactly Marvel Studios is looking at to
play the thing in a new report from The
Insider Jeff Snyder on the hot mic
podcast he revealed that previously he
had heard that for the thing they were
looking to cast a person of color for
the role now we've heard that they might
be doing this for Mr Fantastic so he
could have been talking about Mr
Fantastic but it's irrelevant because he
goes on to say that he has heard that
Marvel Studios is looking to cast a
Jewish actor for the role of Ben Grimm
and this is interesting one because it
makes sense because Ben Grimm is often
portrayed as Jewish in the comics but
it's interesting because if they
seemingly want to go the comic accurate
route making Ben Grimm Jewish then all
of these reports about making Mr
Fantastic a person of color seemed to be
a little bit off there if they want to
make him comic accurate now ultimately
Marvel Studios will go with whatever
they think and whoever they think is the
best decision for the specific role
whether they get a person of color or
they go for Comic accuracy or whatever
it is Marvel Studios will pick the best
actor for the roles they are trying to
cast and typically the casting for
Marvel Studios has been pretty spot on
but having been Graham be Jewish in the
MCU and having a Jewish actor play him
gives us a little bit of an idea on who
exactly Marvel Studios could be eyeing
at one point in time there was a rumor
going around that Marvel Studios was
looking to cast Jason Segal as the thing
well Jason Segal is Jewish so if Marvel
Studios has truly met with Jason Segal
and like we've mentioned in previous
videos Marvel Studios meets with a lot
of actors very frequently about many
different things just to basically see
if there's any role that's come up that
would be a good fit for them and they
can do this every few years call the
actors back and say hey we have some
more new characters coming up do we
think something would be a good fit well
Jason Segal is a very large man he's
very tall and if you're looking for the
thing to be huge well he's got the
height you can make somebody wide just
by the Prosthetics that you put on them
and the big suit that I'm assuming the
actor is going to wear for the thing you
can make them big but Jason Segal is
tall so if you want a massive the thing
he wouldn't be a bad choice plus often
times Ben Grimm provides comic relief
and Jason Segal is a funny man he is
widely known for his comedic roles and
many popular films like Forgetting Sarah
Marshall I love you man many people know
him from How I Met Your Mother but he
does also have a lot of range as an
actor so of course he can be serious as
well another actor that has been rumored
to have met with Marvel Studios for the
role of Ben Grimm is Seth Rogan and he
is also Jewish as well and the same
thing pretty much goes for him that goes
for Jason Segal and the two of them are
actually friends Seth Rogen is primarily
known for his comedic roles in movies
like Knocked Up Pineapple Express the
interview he's a funny guy so he could
also provide that comedic relief in the
movie and again they could just throw a
big old bodysuit on him to make him
really big as the thing so the fact that
we have a report stating that Marvel
Studios is looking for a Jewish actor
and the fact that we've had previous
reports stating that Marvel Studios was
Ein Jason Segal and Seth Rogen to play
the role well that lines up these
reports coincided with the each other so
there's a good possibility that one of
these two could be cast as the thing in
the MCU now moving on to Doctor Strange
three it was reported not too long ago
that Marvel Studios was pretty much fast
tracking Doctor Strange 3 to be made and
come out before Secret Wars and this
makes a lot of sense if you consider the
post-credits scene for Doctor Strange
and the Multiverse of Madness where CLIA
shows up and tells doctor strange that
he has created an incursion and they are
going to fix it well Secret Wars is
going to be about incursions universe is
colliding into each other threatening
the entire Multiverse as everybody knows
it it could lead to the destruction of
the Multiverse that is the main problem
with incursions and this is actually
what he who remains explained during the
first battle for the Multiverse the
first multiversal war the end of the
entire Multiverse almost happened until
he harnessed the power of eliev and
defeated everybody else then created the
sacred timeline now of course Loki and
Sylvie they undid all of that and we
have a bunch of kangarians now but
Doctor Strange three is really going to
dive into the whole concept of
incursions that way we can kind of
understand what is going on in secret
Wars and we have a new report about the
movie from Murphy's multiverse.com
stating that Marvel Studios wants Sam
raymie back to direct Doctor Strange 3
Sam Raimi of course directed Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and
he directed the original Spider-Man
trilogy with Toby Maguire so it looks
like our director for the next movie
could indeed be Sam raymey now before
you go and kind of bad mouth this
because Multiverse of Madness wasn't
exactly that good according to some
people that is the movie has actually
won awards it actually won the People's
Choice Award for best movie of 2022 so
clearly a lot of people actually like
this movie despite what you would read
on the internet but regardless of that
you have to keep in mind that Scott
Derrickson was originally writing and
directing Doctor Strange 2. then he had
the falling out with Marvel and Sam
Raimi came in pretty much halfway into
the movie already being done so he came
into a movie that had a script already
done for it and from there they made
changes and he made his own script but
he came into something that wasn't
exactly ideal if he is involved with
Doctor Strange 3 from the very beginning
which I'm assuming he will be I'm sure
he can make an incredible movie that is
not only dark but also very important to
the Multiverse so looks like we could
have our director or Doctor Strange
three and again it seems like Marvel
Studios needs this to come out before
Secret Wars it doesn't make any sense
for it to come out after and last but
not least you might have caught my video
yesterday talking about what Bob Iger
the CEO of Disney was saying about how
Marvel is going to be moving forward if
you didn't be sure to check out that
video because it is very important for
the future of the MCU but one part of
that was during the conference that he
spoke at he did say that we are about to
see some and I quote here newness in the
MCU specifically in regards to this new
Avengers team that will have new
characters a part of it he specifically
said that if you look at the trajectory
of Marvel in the next five years there
will be a lot to Nunes he then said
we're going to turn back to the Avengers
franchise with a whole new set of
Avengers for example so the new Avengers
team is going to consist of some Heroes
that we've already met and of course
some coming in the future some new
characters hopefully like Nova but Jeff
lovnes who wrote quantumania and who is
writing the King Dynasty has already
opened up and basically told us a few
members that are going to be a part of
the team he said we got Florence Pugh
and Jonathan majors and Leticia Wright
we've got such a deep bench of really
good actors everyone will get their
chance to shine so we have the Atlanta
Bulova we have shuri who is now the New
Black Panther we obviously know
Spider-Man is going to be a part of the
team and based off of the ending of
Xiang Chi and the legend of the ten
Rings it seems like shangchi will be a
part of the new team as well then of
course we have characters like Sam
Wilson's Captain America maybe Bucky
comes back and then like I mentioned the
new characters that are coming hopefully
Daredevil is going to be a part of the
team She-Hulk seems like she's going to
be a part of the team as well and we
can't forget about our OG Avengers we
can't forget about Ant-Man Thor Hulk and
like I mentioned new characters like
Nova coming into the MCU maybe even the
Silver Surfer comes into play because
they're supposed to be a special
presentation about the Silver Surfer so
we have a general idea about who our new
Avengers are going to be and keep in
mind that Jeff loveness has already said
that the Fantastic Four characters and
multiversal characters probably aren't
going to be in his new Avengers film The
Kane Dynasty it's very much going to
focus on our Earth specifically and our
heroes the actual Avengers team so a lot
of exciting stuff coming up in the MCU
be sure to let us know your thoughts and
how excited you are about the future of
the MCU in the comments down below and
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof foreign